Seth Meyers addresses sexual harassment
in Hollywood head-on during his Golden
Globe monologue its 2018 marijuana is
finally allowed and sexual harassment
finally isn't for the male nominees in
the room tonight this is the first time
in three months it won't be terrifying
to hear your name read out loud a 44
year old comedian kicked off the 75th
annual Golden Globe Awards on Sunday by
not shying away from the current climate
in Hollywood calling out specific people
involved in allegations of sexual
misconduct including Kevin Spacey and
Harvey Weinstein but don't worry he'll
be back in 20 years when he becomes the
first person ever booed during the in
memoriam
[Applause]
it'll sound like that ET spoke with Seth
ahead of the show where he opened up
about how his wife human rights attorney
alexei Ashe helped him prepare for the
sensitivity of the 2018 Globes I'm very
lucky to be married to a fearless woman
and so I try to bring that to the stage
on evenings like tonight we have spent a
lot of time talking about it we hope we
have a nice balance of talking about
everything that happened this year while
at the same time celebrating all the
great work everybody did
you